Democratic Republic of Congo's Army has
been fighting the m-23 armed group up
and down this stretch of road for weeks
a Congolese Army Captain took us to the
front line it's near the border with
Rwanda which is widely understood to
back the armed group although Rwanda
denies it
this Soldier says we'll fight them back
to Rwanda whatever support they have
this is one of three front lines where
Congo's Army has fought M23 in recent
weeks this time a year ago M23 only had
a few hundred unarmed Fighters since
then the un's filmed Fighters entering
Congo from Rwanda and Rwandan soldiers
have been photographed among m23s
Fighters the soldiers here say they're
fighting an enemy that's better equipped
than them they say m23s Fighters get
more food more water and that they have
Heavy Artillery hidden on the hilltops
that makes it difficult for them to
fight and Advance
the captain told us their enemies on a
hillside less than a kilometer away M23
has rejected international calls for it
to withdraw and disarm by a deadline
that passed on Friday
Congo's Army says Rwanda wants military
control of this area through its proxy
M23
it's rich with golden coltan mines
Congo's government says M23 can't be
part of the Nairobi peace talks unless
it withdraws and disarms
we don't have time to waste because M23
and Rwanda only understand the voice of
bullets if they don't listen to the
calls of the leaders we'll have to force
them back to the place where they came
from
Congo's military has jet fighters and
new Attack Helicopters military sources
say they're wondering why the government
rarely orders them to bomb m23's
artillery and help the Infantry advance
nearly 300 000 people have fled the
fighting and are living in insanitary
camps many of them also question why the
government's not doing more
our soldiers are fighting with the
rebels but whenever they're about to win
the authorities tell them to stop
fighting for one or two days this is
exactly when the rebels always take
advantage and Advance we were told to
leave the area so that soldiers can
continue to fight
back at the front line soldiers told us
their enemy is used a few days of calm
to bring reinforcements from Rwanda
there's no sign of this conflict ending
soon Malcolm Webb Al Jazeera kibumba
Democratic Republic of Congo